[Music]
hi everyone it's a pleasure to be here
I'm glia batata from Cyprus I live in
Boston I work at Cyprus remotely and I
will talk about the state of art in and
to end testing but before I do that I
have to talk about very very something
important our planet is an immediate
imminent danger like the heat waves
during the summer Arctic without sea ice
burn in California right now India
Bangladesh running out of water
the system is broken and imagine the
heat wave that you experience during the
summer lasting for one month it kills
all the crops what's your plan what's
your plan for melting Arctic and we see
rising 50 metres and I'll tell you there
is no [ __ ] plan so I'm trying to act
and change my behavior today so I only
have one son I cutting down on flying I
only use public transportation try to
eat eat less meat solar farm so on and
I'm trying to tell everyone to do the
same because we can all influence
ourselves and our immediate family and
co-workers and finally you have to
affect the way but government acts in
the United States and trying to lobby
for carbon pricing because I think we
have technology to change our lives
today and the only thing stopping from
changing and averting the global climate
catastrophe is the fossil fuels but
trying to squeeze one more dollar before
we all die here's my pledge here's my
email Twitter if you working on profit
or nonprofit organization but tries to
change our climate and solve it I will
help you for free I volunteer to help
you with testing it's always hard to
kind of switch back from that team but
it's serious okay testing is a drag it
slows you down of thinking
[Applause]
testing is a drug it slows you down
while you're writing tests you cannot
actually do features but you get paid
for and testing doesn't pay
it's like scaffolding you have to build
it in order for you to finish the
building but then you have to remove it
because you're not selling the
scaffolding and finally testing is
boring and I'm surprised so many people
actually picked me because I would
expect everyone to be at a different
stage in this presentation I will tell
you how I personally avoid writing tests
and how I pick which tests to write and
how to make it fun so I have a lot of
open source projects a lot of blog posts
I do run engineering at Cypress so if
you go and github give it the star every
day I'm working on test run or coding
every day these slides are available on
slides that come and finally if you want
to argue with me or praise me I'm on
Twitter as well so why are we writing
tests well I personally I know that I
write shitty code every time I write
something it's not gonna work I know
that in any language for any platform I
notice I'm gonna work on a second try or
third try so the only reason I write
tests is because I know myself so the
simplest way for me to actually prove
myself correct is not write tests but do
a lint chuck so in this case I'm adding
2 vs code ts check and immediately shows
me hey you must stop here's an error for
a couple flinters
so I usually talk about linting pyramid
at the bottom we have prettier pretty
reformats your JavaScript code so it
looks uniform easy to read it's not an
actual inter but it makes the test of
your production code easier to read and
easier to understand and for bugs not to
hide there then you have es lint this is
an actual linter it understands the
structure of your code and it can tell
you you're using a variable that you
have not declared
it's probably the mistake and even above
it is things like TS check but actually
use type information to test my code and
tell me if something is wrong
and you can get all the benefits of type
script checks without writing type
script so here's how you do it you start
with your regular JavaScript code let's
say a function add and you write a
comment I know a comment kind of weird
right but in that comment you can say
first parameter is a number and second
parameter is a number and immediately
you get benefits because if you hover
over the well function every time you
use it
where is intellisense pop-up but tells
you hey this is what was function does
but also can underline and tell you hey
you are trying to pass a string and this
function expects a number so you're
doing something wrong you can actually
set it up as a pre compile step where it
will type check all your JavaScript code
and tell you all the places but you call
in function incorrectly but this brings
me to my biggest pet peeve with every
project I've been on nobody writes
comments even when comments are very
useful so when we were working on our
comments for Cyprus we made a decision
but every method with the API exposes
should be well documented so anytime is
try to write tests you can hover over
let's say type and it tells you here's
what type does here's an example here's
a link to actually find more
documentation where we spent a lot of
time writing ducks for every command
because we know it's very very important
I was thinking why is it important and I
realized that I actually make more
mistakes not even writing my own code
but more mistakes using someone else's
code or more mistakes even using my own
code so here's the situation I write
something an adult that I don't document
it enough I have confusing API maybe I
have options that don't make sense but
are not named correctly so 10 developers
try to use that library they all make
mistakes
they all have to submit an issue look at
the code and so what happens achieved I
became a 10x developer which is my goal
but it's negative ten I just slowed down
ten developers by writing bet code
without examples no one should be an
Einstein to actually use your library
no one should look at the code and know
the whole system just to fix a small
issue
please make nice abstractions document
them to make itself more productive so
use static types linking and please use
more examples I love looking at examples
when people talk about testing they
usually talk about testing pyramid and
they argued till they're blue in the
face about types of tests to ride should
the right Maureen test because they're
faster or should I write more end-to-end
tests because they're more productive
and I say forget about all that
like stop arguing about testing pyramid
if you write in code you should test it
if you writing API you should test it if
you're writing a web application you
should test it it doesn't matter how you
call the test it has to be a test but
it's only a test and only with thing
that you doubt works if your thing is a
function and you're not sure if it works
or not you write a test if you think is
a component in this case a react
component you write a test in this case
Cypress can mount this component and
interact with component and you can run
it and it looks kind of like this where
you can see how your component reacts to
events but you're sending if you thing
is an API volver is plug-in but every
written where you can call your API with
given arguments inspect back results
maybe even show log messages from a
server side I don't care how you call
the test I call it a test if you think
is a complete web application when you
write a cypress test where you visit the
site and you exercise website you drive
it just like a real user so if you think
is not a web application itself but the
style via CSS the visual appearance of
your web app you write a test you just
add plugins from other libraries that do
visual diffing
so in this case if someone submits a
pull request and the pull request
changes with SVG fills style color to
something else
well that test can tell you pizza that
used to be yellow now got a green crust
is that what you wanted and you probably
will say no tomorrow guilt AR will show
how he does visual dipping and visual
testing so make sure not to miss his
presentation he is an excellent
presenter if your thing is not a web
application and not its style but its
accessibility you write a test in the
test you can inject very popular X
accessibility testing library and just
check everything for example in this
case a color contrast and it will tell
you hey you cannot read it right because
the color country is so low so the test
will tell you your website doesn't pass
accessibility tests you can always write
a test it's just a question is picking a
write plug-in but test the thing but
you're trying to prove works
we've Cyprus we created a platform where
people can write in JavaScript plugins
we do all sorts of different things more
than we actually imagined there are two
things that people ask me about testing
what should I test and how long should
my tests be so what should I test but a
couple of ways you can say you have to
write new tests or but tests are
duplicate you can do it manually
carefully collect user stories and for
each user story write an end-to-end test
but the thing but makes it difficult is
that you have to maintain this
one-to-one relationship as you add
features or modify features or even
deprecated features for example this to
do MVC you can say well what does it do
well feature a user can add to-do items
okay users can complete to-do items and
users can delete to-do items
excellent we have three features and
we'll keep track of them manually so we
can write a test and we'll take with
teacher named as the
name so it adds to dos is a task it
completes to those is a task and then we
can think oh wait none of my test is
named delete to do so we write one more
task and it's very simple example but a
thing in general it's a very hard system
to maintain because it's easy to match
one task to one feature but once you
start writing a couple of more features
notice it becomes harder and after a
while you just get swamped
you can not maintain this thing many I
don't know what happened there like this
is weird okay so we need an alternative
alternative is to automate this feature
mapping to test we can collect code
coverage we can instrument our
application code so we know which lines
of code we executed during the tests so
imagine you in starting it to implement
this app and you say feature a users
will be able to add item so you write
some code and then you implement the
second feature and you write some more
code you may be changed old code and
then you implement the last feature
which also adds code and then you run
end to end test and because your code is
already instrumented you can tell which
lines of code those tests touched in
this case martin green and the rest is
red and yellow the red lines are
features that i have not tested and you
played Sherlock Holmes and if you go out
what test to write and you write one
more test and now you're covering all
the lines so that's how code coverage
works and it's not direct measurements
right because it's indirect measurement
you know that both features I
implemented in code and you know this
code gets executed when you run both
tests and people strive to get 100% code
coverage but it doesn't mean but once
you get to 100% code coverage but you'll
have zero box but one problem is that
your code might not not actually
implement with features correctly you
can still cover the code but that code
is doing the wrong things and the second
problem is that your end-to-end test
cases might be unrealistic yes they are
covering
the code but for example they use very
simple email so if a user uses a
realistic email your code might not
actually work so hundred percent code
coverage doesn't guarantee zero bugs so
for Cypress we have written a code
coverage plugin where you instrument the
code which is very easy to do and then
but plugin does the rest
here's how it works you write your test
it's a simple and to end test where a
user visits the site finds the input box
types free to deuce and then checks but
very free to deuce in a list and we
found that end-to-end tests like this
one are extremely efficient at covering
a lot of application source code in a
single test this one test if you look at
the report covers seventy two and a half
percent of all application code just a
single test because the whole
application has to load initialize stop
processing events and then the code
coverage and a hundred percent is not
the goal of itself instead you should
use red code coverage report as a guide
or as a map to which tests to write so
in this case if you look at this test
and you look at the report and you look
inside each source file inside that
report you will see which lines were
executed in this case I'm looking at the
Redux store for the web application and
I can clearly see that the case had to
do was covered because my tests really
added free to do this and in yellow you
see the switch statements that were not
executed and in red you see the source
lines but were not executed by vistas so
you can see we need to write tests but
delete to do edit to do complete to do
and so on it becomes almost like a game
will just see the lines but you have not
tested when you write an end-to-end test
to hit both lines so I've written motifs
and I get ninety nine point two six
percent code coverage just from end to
end test except where's one tiny problem
I can see but one file missed something
so if I look inside that file I can see
a default case statement this little
file implements the view filter do I
want to see all to those active to those
or completely to those and everything is
fine but Antwan test is correct is just
this default statement is not reachable
from end to end interface from a user
interface because my applications
actually wired correctly so in that case
I don't have to write end-to-end tests I
have to write a unit test but just X
gives this piece of code and hits that
line
so I write unit tests by importing wet
class directly and calling it with
invalid filter and cypress can run unit
tests just as well in this case there is
no website but it does execute your code
and various code coverage information
and when I look at the report I can see
what I in this particular unit test I
hit just wet line it was very targeted
specific test and the cool thing is that
cypress can combine information from
end-to-end tests and unit tests and if
you look at the combined report you get
100% code coverage from your test but
run by Cypress but wait where is all
this more so usually my web application
is not just a static site it's not just
a web application it has a back end and
if you're writing our front end in
JavaScript we probably are writing our
back end in JavaScript using node so if
you instrument your node code your
server-side code in practice it's really
easy so here's how you do it instead of
saying npm start and running node server
using start with coverage where you run
a tool called and why c and you say
instrument and start my node code
that's it behind-the-scenes NYC will
instrument every loaded file so when my
back-end is running it actually collects
code coverage information and cypress
implements middlewares where you can
just import depending on the server what
you're using but can return that code
coverage information someone that has
finished Cypress code coverage plug-in
will ask hey give me everything from the
backend side well was covered by this
test and when it just combines
everything and now you get full stack
code coverage from the same end-to-end
tests in this case 91% again you don't
have to exhaustively write with us
because Anto and tests are extremely
effective at covering all parts of run
even more tomorrow make sure not to miss
Davis presentation so he's advocating
and shows examples and has libraries
that show final state machines that can
drive application and if you can derive
your application from finite state
machines you can also derive your tests
automatically from but final state
machine it becomes a graph problem so in
this case both tests are not written by
me instead I ask what final state
machine give me all the possible paths
for a tic-tac-toe game give me all the
drawers and a single win for X and a
single win for all and when Cyprus
France was test and this test were
automatically generated and I know that
it's exhaustive set of tests because
it's exhaustive set of paths in the
finite state machine excellent so please
use code coverage not as a goal don't
strive to kill yourself achieving 100%
code coverage instead look at the code
coverage report and use missing lines as
a guide to the test that you want to
write don't look at the number by itself
don't look at 92 or 94 but instead on
every poor quest try to see a very
sudden change if that number drops on a
poor quest you probably have written
code
but you haven't tested or you emitted
some necessary tests so it's the Delta
in code coverage that matters not the
number itself and finally like I'm
really interested in looking beyond this
simple lines of code code coverage
number so state machine code coverage is
important metric I think and a second
question that people ask is that if I'm
writing lots of tests some of my tests
are short some tests along usually
end-to-end tests are more realistic so
they're longer how long is too long so a
lot of unit tests a lot of short tests
that we write are very short and they
follow a couple of steps but first they
arrange some data we may be importing a
function set up arguments when they call
what function with arguments they act
and then they get results and they have
a single assertion anything both tests
are short and have usually a single
assertion not because it's useful but
because most of tests so far but are we
running run in a terminal so if a test
fails it becomes extremely extremely
difficult to debug a long test because
it might have multiple sources and
multiple points of failure because we
would have to rerun things in terminal
maybe enable debug logs concentrate on
that particular test so the terminal is
not a good environment for running tests
and debugging we're failures and I'm
here to tell you it's okay to write
longer tests if you have a better test
Runner it's fine like start writing
tests now rightly realistic test a test
but represents a typical use case where
a human comes in and uses your system in
this case I'm testing a medium clone
right where I'm writing a new blog post
and filling all the fields and when
submitting comment because where is the
command log on the Left right now I'm
hovering over each command from my test
and it shows how the app looked during
Wed step I can even click on a command
open dev tools and debug you know xhr
call for example in details and see
everything with the application and my
test before
and so eva is a failure somewhat in the
middle of a test i can debug it easily i
can see the behavior of app and i can
understand why it failed even before
what assertion advant and still it's
easy to get carried away everyone has
their own time tolerance but i would
save it for me anything longer than 20
30 seconds is way too long of a test to
work with effectively because every time
I change something it has to way go for
30 seconds of stuff before I know if my
last command is passing or not so here's
a typical example imagine you testing
this multi-page form so you feel all the
fields on the first page click next fill
all the fields on the second page click
next and then feel everything on a last
page before you actually you know click
sign up I slowed down typing here just
to prove my point so this is way too
long of a test and it goes through the
setup of multiple pages just to confirm
the design app works what can we do to
make it better we can split it into
three tests but wait if I'm filling each
page separately how it might last page
get all the data but it needs to sign up
well the way you do this is that each
test and with a check point almost like
a game check point where you save
yourself and then respond later every
new test doesn't start from a very
beginning instead it starts immediately
from a previously saved check point
here's how it looks in my application if
I am running inside Cypress I will
expose the app reference variable now my
tests can access the application if I
can do that when I can write a frost
test that only feels the frost page goes
to the second page and stops and at the
very last command after it stops it
grabs one window grab that a preference
accesses very dark State and make sure
that it's correct
it does deep equal and has a big object
with all fields but I expect but form to
feel so I know my tests go through page
and ends in the same internal
application state as I expect it to be
and here's the start of a second test
the very first command my test does it
goes to the window grabs the application
reference and in a single call says set
your internal state into a check point
object and when it starts filling
refills so here's the second test and
here's me hovering over just sad state
command EC have application immediately
switches from frost page to the
beginning of a second page and its
internal data is set exactly the same
way as if it filled everything on the
first page but now I kinda like respond
at the start of a second page and to
application makes no difference if I
fill the page or just reset the state
every state starts at the last
checkpoint of a previous almost like
really erasing so I want to finish with
a summary please please please document
your code if you're writing JavaScript
and I look at your library and it
doesn't have examples I'll be very angry
and I don't want to be angry the code
coverage would have shown is not a
target of itself it's just a tool for
you to write tests that cover something
else and don't repeat themselves and
finally don't accept slow tests where
are better ways to test so you don't
have to wait for hours and hours and
hours for them to finish thank you and
shoot for the stars thank you
thank you so much Claire we actually
have a bunch of questions for you oh wow
so we are not going to be able to answer
all of them so let's start what do you
think about new mutation tests
I love mutation the mutation testing
means you take the source code of your
application and then randomly change
variable or command and when you run all
the tests and you see if tests actually
fail if you actually did detect a
mutation and if it don't that means your
tests are not covering your application
very well so I'm all for exploring
mutation I didn't have time to implement
it yet but if you want to talk to me I'm
all for it next question the cyber
support other browsers than Chrome if
not then we'll be in future No so we
support Chrome we're coming out with
supporting edge beta and brave because
they actually run on chromium but we
have a pull request with Firefox support
we have 3,000 full browser tests passing
in chrome and out of 3,000 tests in
Firefox we have only 15 failing so it's
like this close this close we're coming
out with Firefox support can I use
Cypress to test react native no so
Cypress is only for anything which runs
in the browser if you haven't converted
every react native to the native app you
probably can test it in a browser but
afterwards unfortunately no checkpoints
are only working with red X how would
you do it with react contacts so with
checkpoint scan it's just an example but
they used every application we can
control it you can control it from end
to end test and set its state or set its
internal properties so it should work
with every platform we have examples for
view and angular and anything under the
Sun how to check if my test is good the
quality of it I have doubts that I'm
testing right and it disappeared now
it's there testing ratings rights and
areas I would say the person who doubts
that they have written a good test and
they actually trying to see if it's good
it's already on a path to writing good
tests because they're doubting
themselves and they're trying to improve
I'm not sure what makes a good test but
I think if you review the test with your
team just like we review your production
code you can agree on a quality test the
cyber support integration in you guys
give 1c ICD so you can run Cypress on
your machine locally on every continuous
integration platform go to our Doc's we
have example and running on every
platforming including gitlab how to
service mock calls to and from API it
marks and beautifully go to our Doc's
look at what documentation for network
stabbing you can spy and stop on Ajax
calls from the application we come in
with future we can you stop and spy
everything like everything is cypress
using percy for visual tests cypress is
just a tool and then there are plugins
for visual testing so Percy has written
their own library to make sure over 20 I
press runs it sends the thing to Percy
applicants has written a library for
Cypress as a plugin so you can send
things to applitools vero open source
image comparison libraries where cypress
can generate snapshot and let bet
library will do visual different for you
so it's both commercial and open source
things just go to a plugins page to find
them it's possible to test react
typescript with Cypress yes alright
earthquake we have problems running
service tests on a CI requests often
time out when doing CY wait is this a
known Cyprus problem or could be
something on our side do remember I said
but I write bad code right so everything
bad code and it fails right if you give
us a producible example will debug it
and we'll fix it it's red extra state
committed to versioning system if yes
isn't it too hard to maintain this just
in long run a store is extended yes so
you can meet it because I used it as an
object it's up to you what to do but if
you for example use just match snapshot
it's kind of a same thing you have a
trade-off between large fixture objects
versus the tests so you have to pick
your battles
is it possible to extract test results
in eg g-unit Foreman or code coverage in
different form
yes so Visayas plugins save the coverage
report in multiple formats and you can
configure additional ones so you can
send it everywhere I'm gonna say last
three questions how do we ete test and
slow api okay you don't if your api
calls and to entrant are slow you
Malcolm who should rate Cyprus test
front-end developer or the QA I think
the developers who's working on
application should write end-to-end test
I mean QA can run them write them but
when you working on a tool but test help
you to actually write better code right
away last question glove what about
integration of Cyprus with visual
regression testing like taking
screenshots when running some tests and
comparing images just like I said for
Percy and applitools for plugins that
use open source local tools but do image
comparison so just go to our plugins
page or we have a visual testing guide
in our documentation that covers pretty
much every scenario thank you so much
clear as you can
[Music]